what is up everybody happy Wednesday no
happy Thursday morning super excited to
be here for another gratitude journal
livestream episode number for this has
actually been a lot of fun for me I've
been enjoying sharing this with you uh
the [ __ ] first time here I don't even
if even if you've been on all for the
purpose here is to have a daily reminder
of the things that we're grateful for
because your gratitude will lead to
happiness your gratitude will help you
out of the hole that you're in your
gratitude will help you appreciate the
things that you have in life and this is
something that I did with my team every
day through a private facebook group and
I thought would bring it to you guys as
well so you could benefit from all the
all the benefits that we've realized by
doing this the beauty is getting longer
by the day Nina's not too happy about it
but we'll see probably weekend it's
going to come out so you get to enjoy
the beauty for now the key thing here is
we're figuring out three things that we
are grateful for I want you guys to
share it up on the live chat for those
of you watching afterwards put it down
in the comments below and don't just
list things off it's important that you
actually feel it because it's really
hard to hold gratitude in your mind and
anger or hate or you know depression or
you know something negative it's hard to
hold both in your mind at the same time
and so hopefully we're creating a nation
of happier healthier entrepreneurs
through this process so I'm going to go
through mine first and I gotta read off
yours and I'm excited to see what you
guys are grateful for and one last
reminder I guess that this is this has
to be a this has to be a daily practice
right like I Do's every day I'm sharing
with you this week but we do this every
day because you need it every day
because every day is a new day just like
motivation we need it every day just
like brushing your teeth you know you
need it every day you brush your teeth
for your oral hygiene and you show
gratefulness for your mental hygiene you
need every day so for me my three things
today
I'm really grateful that I was honest
last night I had a tough conversation
with somebody and there was there was an
easy answer there was an actor that
everybody would have been okay with it
just kind of made logical sense of why
someone didn't get something but it
wasn't the truth and I felt like I felt
like this guy deserved the truth for
everything that he's kind of contributed
and help with and I told them I told
them that you know what there's an easy
answer I could have been easy for me to
come out and say this but it's not the
truth and you deserve the truth and you
respect that and that's sometimes a
difficult thing to do and sometimes the
truth can hurt more than it helps so you
got a way that judgment call but I'm
really grateful that we had that talk
and I told him the truth and he he
respected that so that's it's a muscle
to build eat out tough conversations
it's a muscle to build but the more you
back down from them the more you get
used to backing down from them and just
kind of reinforces you thinking small
and plain small so you get that
opportunity to challenge yourself and do
something outside that comfort zone have
that tough conversation you want to
start getting used to doing it even if
doesn't work out the first time you know
you fail most times on the first time
number two for me is I'm really grateful
for all the people i have on today this
is a crazy day we have six live streams
today including this one i'm super
excited about my guests in the afternoon
as well as the only legal legends ones
coming up in six minutes mm-hmm um yeah
a lot a lot of like Thursday's are my
public-facing day I don't know that I
usually have I think six hangouts might
be a record
but I'm really excited to help you guys
to help other entrepreneurs to help
myself get some ideas and wisdom so
super grateful for the guests and I'm
going to have on and the questions that
I'm going to be able to ask I don't
really know what's going to happen yet
so I love the spontaneity too and the
creativity that will flow when we get on
to a live call um the third thing I'm
grateful for my increased self-awareness
I recognized as an example that me I'm
you know I'm naturally an introvert
there may not come across you know I've
said a couple times in the channel but
when I'm around people too much it it
drains me uh and in general I don't like
going to networking events or weddings
or parties or that kind of stuff i don't
i don't need to like ketchup or hang out
I'd rather I'd rather I'd rather work
I'd rather to mice my thing the flip
side of that is helping entrepreneurs is
so meaningful to me that when I'm around
entrepreneurs something changes you know
I lose my introverted pneus and I just
want to help so tonight we have a night
off which is kind of rare usually Nina
and I have something going on whether
it's with the business or Toronto dance
salsa and tonight's fully off and I I
told Nina that I'm gonna crash hard
tonight so whatever we do it's just like
I just want to be home with you relax
you know watch some arrow we just got
into the hero series on TV um because I
know that at the end of this day with
this with the six hangouts and the phone
calls after making between in the
meetings I'm gonna be I'm gonna give
everything you know hopefully if you
guys are sticking around all the TN you
won't see me like massively flame out
and burn on the last one I feel like I'm
going to give everything but after that
i'm going to crash heart and so having
the self-awareness not to then like book
something tonight or I'm going out
then not being happy and you know
disappointed myself and the people
around me so that's it that's what I'm
grateful for today let's see what you
guys have shared up in the live chat we
got me she kept TV whew good morning
everyone they know hey y'all time to
share our gratitude Zeno's up today and
grateful for my body that gets a lot of
junk thrown into it it still manages to
okay so you know we love you man you
know let's uh get a little bit on the
healthy side here apple a day huh to my
cats who are very comforting by just
being there and don't judge and are
negative in any way it's super
interesting that it's true like pets
don't judge I'm more of a dog person but
no matter how crappy a day you've had
when you come home to it you're happy
pet they just they love you no matter
what I think it's why people have pets
so I feel you there i went on the pet
right now Nina really wants to get a dog
I she wants to get a dog which doesn't
want to pick up after the dog so we'll
have to see what happens there and three
my right hand because being right-handed
things would be quite difficult having
only having a left one I like it I like
it and never thought about that but yes
I'm grateful that I have two arms and
two limbs you will do stuff with as well
what else we got what else we got oh man
the list loads so quickly on here uh if
you to build adjust and welcome aboard
Jay Reise how do you guys get so how do
you guys get in here so early I don't
know how do you guys get in here so
early I came on if people already in the
chat you guys you guys let me know I'm
curious too Chandi what if one is good
for nothing how do I appreciate what
I've gotten stop complaining that's the
point of the exercise like when I
started this I had a hard time thinking
stuff as well it took me a long time i
SAT here and I figured out three pretty
quickly but there's so many things that
you just get used to and I think it's
easy to naturally default to the big
things like your parents and you know
relationships and health and stuff which
are that's great great to be a great
be grateful for but also thinking about
the little things like the internet like
believe nation like you know the Apple
you ate today or having your right hand
you know all those things just thinking
about that you know Xena I never thought
about having my right hand zaino
thinking about that mentioning that now
makes me grateful that I have my right
hand to control my mouse and don't do
all the things that I need to do and so
hopefully even by being in this chat and
by listening in you start thinking about
some things in your life that you're
grateful for when he's talking about his
cat I'm thinking about you know the dog
I used to have my parents dog and um
makes me feel big full even more painful
than three things that I had in mind so
I think it's just a daily practice it's
a struggle at the start some for some
people was a struggle for me for others
and may come super easily but for me it
was a struggle and hopefully with
practice you'll be able to get there and
you could join in every day join in
tomorrow we'll say we keep this series
going it's at least going till tomorrow
that's it guys 910 is crazy how quickly
10 minutes goes have an amazing day if
you guys want some business advice and
we're doing a live stream right now
league of legends on my twitch channel
answering business questions hope you
guys rock today rock the thursday if you
join me on the live chats that are
coming up later that'd be awesome
continue to believe whatever your one
word is and i'll see you soon